جون جاسي او القاتل المهرج واحد من اشهر
المجرمين في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
تهمه بقتل 33 طفلا بين عامي
1972 و
1978 ارتدى ثياب المهرجين وابتسم
ابتسامتهم لكنه استبدل تلك الالوان
الزاهيه بالوان القتل والاغتصاب والابتزاز
والشذود
33 طفلا المكان الولايات المتحده الحكم
الاعدام
ولد الجنسيه عام 1942 في احدى قرى ولايه
الينوي الامريكيه وعشا طفوله عاديه ثم
اصبح معروفا بتواصله الاجتماعي وعمله
كمهرج في المناسبات الخيريه وحفلات
الاطفال لكن سرعان ما ابهر ميولا ساديه
بدا جرائم وجسي وصداماته مع القانون عام
68 بعد ان اذن بالاعتداء جنسيا على الطفل
المراهق و احتجز في احدى الاصلاحيات وخضع
للعلاج النفسي ثم اخرج عنه بعد سنتين
بمرور السنين انطلقت من المنزل روائح
كريهه شعر بها السكان والجيران لكن جسي
اقنعهم ان الرطوبه الزائده والمتراكمه
داخل المنزل هي سبب انبعاث تلك الروائح
لكن ما لم يكن يعلمه جيران جزيلا ان ارضيه
المنزل تحوي بين تربتها 29 جثه من ضحايا
الجسي
عمى 78 وبلغت الشرطه باختفاء فتى يدعى
روبرت وبعد التحقيق علمت الشرطه ان اخر
شخص التقى به هو القاتل المهرجون
حصلت الشرطه على ابن بتفتيش المنزل وكانت
المفاجاه على مدار السنوات السابقه ان جسم
اعتدى جنسيا على 29 فتى ثم قتلهم خنقا
ودفنهم في فناء منزله كما عثرت الشرطه على
اربع جثث لشبان اخرين لم يجد جسي مكانا في
منزله ليدفنهم لكنه القاهم في النهر
القريب من المنزل
ادعى جسر الجنون وطلب محامه ببراءته
مستعينين بشهادات اطباء نفسيين شخصوا
حالته بالفصام لكن المحكمه رفضت تلك
الادعاءات
حكم على جسم بالاعدام عام 1980 واودع
السجن 14 عاما حتى تلقى اخيرا الحقنه
المميته عام 94 وانتهت معه قصه واحد من
اشهر القتلات الامريكين الذين هزت جرائمهم
كوكب الارض
[موسيقى]